I'm very blessed my parents have been
married for uh 47 years
um they're still very much in love with
each other they're very happy
um even with my wider family Aunts
Uncles brothers sisters
happy marriages right so I I've I'm in
an environment where I'm fortunate to be
able to see lots of positive examples of
this institution working well right I'm
also from a Nigerian background I'm not
like totally westernized
um I grew up in Saudi Arabia in the
Middle East so my perspective is not
kind of the same as someone who just was
born and raised in California or in
London or whatever but I see what's
going on and the thing is even from the
conservative perspective like all
conservatives are very Pro pro-marriage
you know pro-family we need to bring
back the family unit we need to and if
you want to do that seriously Beyond
just talking you have to understand
why why are young men
skeptical about marriage now why are so
many relationships not going the
distance what is what's going on because
the way it is right now
we're in this bizarre situation where
legally and socially there's one foot in
this sort of progressive secular world
and then the other foot in the
traditional more religiously influenced
world and it doesn't it doesn't mix well
so if you look at the laws the laws
around you know whether it's divorce
alimony child custody you know the way
that these things are written and also
the way that they work out in practice
it's all based on this sort of like
1950s idea of you know the man is the
soul bread winner
um the woman's going to be destitute if
you know them if the marriage fails uh
alimony needs to be paid by the it's all
based on you know a more sort of more uh
a sort of code of chivalry almost right
it's based on that old school world but
then there's also now you know you know
complete no fault divorce and there's
just oh you know culturally oh you know
girl if you're not happy just like go
just it's so these things don't blend
well it's like you you you kind of have
to pick one or the other when I look at
the uh marriages that work very well
it's typically conservative religious
framing right conservative religious
people and they're doing it just by the
book
gender roles this is what the man does
this is the what the woman does boom
till death do us apart we don't really
care about the state this is before God
and neither of us are going to break
that and that works
um but this sort of mix of the two where
people are trying to have their cake and
eat it too and you want to be uh you
know strong independent women but you
also want to have the husband there but
you don't really need him but you also I
don't know it's just it's not working
and I think unless unless people are
willing to talk about it and say oh okay
let's talk to these guys in their 30s
20s 30s 40s when you start having those
conversations then you know the female
first primary social order starts to
push back and they say things like so
what do you want to do you want us to go
back to the 1950s you want us to go back
to a place in time where women were just
property and they didn't have
Independence and they didn't have the
ability to go and earn and make money
it's like all right here we go and it's
like you know they want to take you to
this like weird Zone that whenever ever
going to go back to you know let's yeah
let's just be honest but I mean you know
you were talking about the numbers
before when it comes to things like
marriage and you you know you've got
like the religious component you've got
the cultural issues you've got you know
well my family my extended family and
all that family it works well and we've
done it forever and they've you know
they've been married and loving all that
sort of stuff but that's that's an old
um social contract that doesn't really
exist today I mean one of the one of the
strongest indicators that you're
choosing a good we'll just call it wife
stock you know like a good mother for
your kids like Good Wife sock would be a
woman that
um hasn't been promiscuous in her past
there's a study out there I think it's
called the teachman study and I think it
tracks the data there's one that tracks
it up to a dozen past partners and
there's one that tracks it up to I think
25 or something like that but either way
the data is conclusive that if if you
get if you invite a woman into your life
as a wife that has been with nobody
she's a virgin she is yours and that is
it the chances you of getting divorced
after eight years is something like five
percent is very very low
um even after I think uh four Partners
four past partners the the data starts
to drop to like 40 50 and it you know
just gets worse in there like the chance
of you getting divorced after
um seven or eight years if she's had
four Partners is something like 40 or 50
percent higher than a woman that's
averted and where do you find these
women that don't have promiscuous past
today if they've been told for decades
through culture and Society you go girl
uh men and women are equal if men can be
promiscuous then women can too without
consequence
um and you know you see this all the
time on these uh shows these podcasts
where these guys sit down with a table
full of women and they don't really
solve anything or get any answers all
they do is they seem to make an example
of you know today's modern women and
they call them you know today's modern
women who just will unapologetically sit
there and be like I'm gonna do what I
want to do I don't need no man I'm happy
being single if a guy doesn't want to
choose me I don't care if he doesn't
like my past so you've got the spread
where you've got but men that are
rational deductive thinkers that are
looking for solutions to their
reproductive strategies in their life
and you know whether or not they want to
have a family or not and some of them
are just putting their hands up and just
being like
I'm out yeah you know it's just not
worth competing I can't compete uh if I
do compete then I put my entire net
worth at risk and potentially lose
actually
one of the most devastating things that
happens to men that go through divorce
and only men that have been through
divorce that lost to that game is
the whole sales pitch to getting married
have kids is you pass on your name you
pass on your DNA you leave a legacy
behind and if that can be stolen from
you because family law or the state has
legislation written into it that's so
hostile towards fathers that she can
take the kids primarily or even you know
conclusively and alienate him from his
own children while he is robbed at his
point of deposit so his paycheck let's
say where he's garnish and it all goes
to her and she just uses the money to
alienate him from his kids like that's a
reality for a lot of men today it's a
sad reality because they signed up for
you know for forever and ever sickness
and health till death do his partner all
that sort of stuff and they don't get
that at the end of the day and there's
no protective mechanisms there in place
for men so men are now saying well is it
worth it should I even do it you know
what do I do about this what are
potential Solutions there's certain
things that you can do to minimize the
risk obviously
um you know select a partner that
doesn't have a whole bunch of red flags
like one of the more controversial
chapters in my book is the 20 red flag
chapter you don't even have to buy the
book you can get it for free if you go
to my email list and just opt in but
um I break down the most obvious red
flags that I've seen over the last few
years with my experience the guys that
I've consulted the guys that call into
my podcast and it's always the same sort
of stuff it's like this is this is
damage like this is these are bruises
these are these are wounds that women
carry that yes you can invite them into
your life yes you can marry them a lot
of guys do but the chances you
complicating your life unnecessarily and
putting your wealth your access to your
kids in the future at risk also go up
dramatically as well so you tend to want
to avoid those and then the big argument
guys have is well you're basically
describing a man because if she doesn't
have any of those red flags and that's a
dude
yeah like you get the um you know you
get the notion it's it's a very
difficult conversation and my granddad
never had that conversation no you know
he never had that problem there was no
social media there was there's no only
fans there was no seeking Arrangements
there was no you go girl and do whatever
you want you know none of that existed I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out